elle a une la fin du g7 après trois
jours de discussions où les grandes
puissances appelle la russie je cite a
cessé ses activités déstabilisatrices à
pékin dans le viseur également et il
était question de la pandémie le g7
s'est engagé à distribuer un milliard de
vaccins et demande une enquête plus
poussée de l'om est à l'origine du
coronavirus en chine en israël la
knesset vote pour entériner le nouveau
gouvernement formé par yaïr lapid s'ils
le valident ce sera la fin du règne
benyamin nétanyahou est l'actuel premier
ministre là sur ce n'est pas terminé
pour lui
il compte rester en politique et
reprendre la main
et puis sans surprise les législatives
anticipées en algérie marquée par un
très faible taux de participation un peu
plus de 30% une frange de l'opposition
et les partisans du irak avait appelé au
boycott du scrutin
les opérations de vote se sont
généralement déroulées dans le calme
sauf en kabylie où quelques incidents
sont à noter
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le g7 et ses
intentions le sommet des grandes
puissances est achevée sur une note de
diplomatie et de solidarité pandémie
oblige g7 s'engage à distribuer plus
d'un milliard de doses de vaccin anti
coville 19 dans le monde d'ici la fin
le g7 exige par ailleurs que la lumière
soit faite sur l'origine du virus en
demandant qu'une enquête plus poussée de
l' oms en chine côté géopolitique les
participants ont appelé la russie je
cite a cessé ses activités
déstabilisatrices côté russe on a donc
réagi regarder nous appelons la russie a
enquêté d'urgence a expliqué de manière
crédible et à fournir des explications
crédibles sur l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques sur son sol à mettre fin à la
répression systématique de la société
civile et des médias indépendants et à
identifier et à faire rendre des comptes
à ceux qui à l'intérieur de ses
frontières mène des attaques par rançon
j ciel les pays du g7 ont adopté une
déclaration commune qui outre l'appel
traditionnelle à la russie de mettre fin
à ces comportements des stabilisateurs
présente un aspect intéressant
le groupe a exprimé son intérêt pour des
relations stables et prévisibles avec la
fédération de russie
avant il avait pour habitude de dire que
la russie devait être plus stable et
prévisible
maintenant cet objectif est considérée
comme faisant partie des relations
communes c'est-à-dire dépendant de
toutes les parties considérant que notre
prévisibilité et confirmé par les années
et les actes la balle est dans le camp
du g7 qui n'est pas particulièrement bon
dans ce domaine
une unité des dirigeants du g7 bien
moins évidente hier au moment d'aborder
la question du break site
retour sur une journée de discussions
avec loïc qui fait le break site
bouscule un g7 placée sous le signe de
l'unité le sommet organisé sur le
territoire britannique a été marquée par
des discussions tendues entre le royaume
uni et ses voisins européens
en ligne de mire les engagements
économiques de londres envers l'irlande
du nord
après un vif échange entre emmanuel
macron et boris johnson
londres reproche à bruxelles son
approche trop stricte du protocole
nord-irlandais et demande plus de
respect les très hauts responsables de
l'ue eux parlent de l'irlande du nord
comme si c'était un pays distinct du
royaume uni ce n'est pas seulement
insultant cela a des effets concrets sur
les communautés
vous vous imaginez ce qui se passerait
si on parlait de la catalogne de la
partie flamande de la belgique d'un land
allemand de l'italie du nord de la corse
pour la france comme de pays différents
il faut un peu de respect sous la
pression de bruxelles la province
britannique est resté dans le marché de
la zone euro afin d'éviter une frontière
terrestre avec sa voisine du sud la
république d'irlande
membre de l'union européenne depuis 1973
emmanuel macron s'est dit prêt à se
rapprocher du royaume uni à la seule
condition que les britanniques respecte
la parole donnée aux européens et le
cadre défini par les accords de break
site
angela merkel préconise elle de trouver
une solution pragmatique le président
américain joe biden d'origine irlandaise
tout comme l'union européenne ne
souhaitant pas faire renaître les vieux
démons éviter un conflit sanglant
l'accord du vendredi saint et la paix
sur l'île d'irlande sont primordiaux
nous avons négocié un protocole qui le
préserve signés et ratifiés par le
royaume uni et bruxelles nous voulons
les meilleures relations possibles avec
le royaume uni
les deux parties doivent mettre en
oeuvre ce sur quoi nous nous sommes mis
d'accord il y à une unité européenne
complète à ce sujet le premier ministre
britannique demande à bruxelles de faire
preuve d'un peu plus de souplesse
boris johnson a averti qu' le royaume
uni n'hésitera pas à passer outre
certaines dispositions du protocole
nord-irlandais en invoquant l'article 16
de l'accord du bric site qui l'y
autorisent
en cas de graves difficultés économiques
sociétales ou environnemental
les images du g7 sur la côte britannique
n'ont pas fait oublier la scène de mardi
quand emmanuel macron a reçu une gifle
quelques jours plus tard place à la
farine âge de françois de rugy jean luc
mélenchon à nantes vendredi pourra le
député la reine à paris hier lors de la
marche contre l'ultra droite pour le
chef de file de la france insoumise les
détails c'est avec robin tu es la
semaine agitée pour les représentants de
la classe politique des élus de tous
bords ont été attaqués alors qu'ils
participaient à des rassemblements
publics vendredi
françois de rugy candidats lrm aux
élections régionales en pays de la loire
a été en farine et alors qu'il se
trouvait avec plusieurs de ses
colistiers dans les rues de nantes ce
samedi c'est au tour de jean luc
mélenchon d'être pris à partie lors de
la marche des libertés à paris des
incidents sans gravité mais condamné par
de nombreux élus qui dénoncent une
banalisation de la violence
on voit bien que à les forces
réactionnaires conservatrice voire
fasciste ou trop au proto fasciste à g
la confiance et font preuve de violence
de violence verbale de violence en ligne
et compris de violences physiques il ya
quelques jours c'est le président de la
république qui a été agressée alors il
ya un titre c'est l'expression en fait
de la radicalisation de ces secteurs-là
des secteurs militants violents et c'est
ce sur quoi nous alertons une réalité
perceptible jusqu'au plus haut sommet de
l'état
ce mardi le président de la république
en déplacement dans la drôme a été giflé
par un homme
immédiatement interpellé son agresseur a
été condamné à 18 mois de prison dont
quatre ferme en comparution immédiate
emmanuel macron a souhaité condamné les
attaques contre les élus tout en
relativisant son cas personnel il ne
faut rien accepter des débordements à
l'égard de celles et ceux qui
représentent une autorité publique
mais je ne veux pas en quelque sorte
exagérer la portée de cet acte sur la
violence par elle-même dans la société
j'en ai beaucoup parlé
c'est là où je relativise ray ce qui
s'est passé la violence c'est ce que
subissent les femmes qui meurent sous
les coups de leur compagnon leur
conjoint la violence c'est ce que
subissent trop de nos concitoyens quand
ils rentrent chez eux qui sont dans les
transports ça c'est la violence même si
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau la
multiplication des actes violents contre
les politiques interpelle à quelques
jours du premier tour des élections
régionales et à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle ces événements renforcent
le sentiment d'une hystérisation du
débat politique et d'une fracture qui
s'élargit entre les aspirations
populaires et la tête de l'état alors
comment expliquer que les politiques
soient pris pour cible écoutez l'analyse
de pierre yves rougeyron lé président du
cercle aristote et directeur de la revue
perspectives libre on à acclimater la
violence politique
mais c'est les politiques qui l'ont
commencée pour beaucoup de français les
urnes apparaissent comme inopérantes
je vous rappelle qu'à eu par exemple des
records d'abstention il ya moins d'une
semaine dans des législatives partielles
l'abstention est la seule vraie grande
question des régionales
donc malheureusement quand les urnes ne
valent plus rien par manque
d'effectivité des décisions publiques
par manque de représentativité
eh bien on va vers d'autres modes
d'expression dont malheureusement cette
utilisation disons spectaculaire au sens
de de bord de la petite violence ou
peut-être un jour de la grande fait
partie le général lecointe à quitte son
poste de chef d'état major a désarmé une
décision prise en accord avec le
président de la république la rumeur de
son départ circulé depuis quelques
semaines et sera donc effectif à partir
du 14 juillet
et c'est le général thierry burkhard de
chef d'état major de l'armée de terre
qui devrait lui succéder à c'est lui qui
devra mettre en oeuvre la fin de
l'opération marqué l'annoncé le 10 juin
écoutez justement l'analyse de dominique
trinquant et ancien général en cire chef
de la mission militaire française à
l'onu et expert en géostratégie le
général lecointe a eu 59 ans au mois de
février 59 ans et de la date normale de
départ à la retraite d'un général donc
il l'a annoncé lui-même il en a discuté
avec le président au mois de novembre en
lui disant qu'il souhaitait partir après
quatre ans de mandat c'est à dire un peu
au mois de juillet et ainsi ne pas faire
coller son mandat avec un mandat
présidentiel pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion entre le serviteur de l'état
nommés et un président élu
la loi de programmation militaire
actuelle augmente mais bien sûr il
faudra poursuivre cet effort il le
souligner il s'agissait de reconstruire
les armes et qui aurait été dans une
situation très difficile si on n'avait
pas engagé 7
cette reconstruction des armées donc oui
grosse d'efforts depuis quatre ans mais
cet effort doit être poursuivie bien sûr
toujours en france cette nouvelle fête
géante hier soir sur l'esplanade des
invalides
après celle de vendredi avec plusieurs
centaines de personnes sans respect des
règles de distanciation social vous le
voyez sans port du masque sur place la
police a fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
en représailles à des tirs de
projectiles trois personnes ont été
interpellées
on en vient à la situation sanitaire de
l'autre côté de la manche le
gouvernement britannique doit s'exprimer
demain sur la levée des dernières
restrictions dans le pays une annonce
attendue et ce alors qu le variant
indien delta progresse là bas le premier
ministre boris johnson à d'ailleurs fait
part de son inquiétude face à la
situation et le dé confinement total
pourrait être menacée on fait le point
avec estelle phare le variant delta
pourrait bien venir compromettre la
levée des derniers
restrictions sanitaires en vigueur au
royaume uni initialement prévu pour le
21 juin la dernière phase du
déconfinement outre manche prévoient
notamment la réouverture des
discothèques le retour du service au bar
mais aussi les rassemblements et mariage
sans limitation du nombre de personnes
face à la progression du variant delta
dans le pays boris johnson a averti ce
week end
la situation est préoccupante il est
clair que le variant indien et plus
transmissible et que les cas et les
niveaux d'hospitalisation augmente
maintenant nous ne savons pas exactement
dans quelle mesure cela va se traduire
par une surmortalité et mais il s'agit
clairement d'une question très très
préoccupante selon une étude du public
halflings l'an les autorités sanitaires
britanniques le variant delta seraient
environ 60% plus contagieux que son
prédécesseur ce variant initialement
identifiés en inde aurait infecté plus
de quarante deux mille trois cents
personnes et représenterait 90 % des
nouveaux cas dans le pays mais données
rassurantes toutefois s'il variant on
progresse le nombre d'hospitalisations
lui ne suis pas le même rythme notamment
grâce à la poursuite de la vaccination
les données indiquent que le programme
de vaccination continue à atténuer
l'impact de ce variant si la vaccination
notre meilleure défense réduit le risque
de maladies graves
elle ne l'éliminent pas selon plusieurs
médias britanniques et notamment le
quotidien the times downing street
pourrait opter vers un report de la
levée des dernières restrictions et ce
pour quatre semaines
mais l'équation est difficile et de
nombreux experts plaident pour une levée
totale des restrictions le 21 juin comme
prévu
c'est le cas par exemple du directeur de
l' institute of economic faire selon lui
un report je cite pourrait porter le
coup de grâce à un secteur qui comptait
sur l'été pour récupérer ses pertes
de plus ce report pourrait engendrer
plus d'un milliard de livres de pertes
par semaine boris johnson milla sur
aucune décision n'a encore été prise
l'annoncé officielle est prévue ce lundi
le pérou dépasse les 2 millions de cas
de contamination une semaine après à la
fin du scrutin à présidentielle
là et toujours aucun vainqueur
officiellement déclaré mais des
accusations d'irrégularités rejetée par
les observateurs étrangers et des
tensions entre partisans des deux
candidats
keiko fujimori continuent d'évoquer des
fraudes alors que pedro castillon en
tête vendredi se déclare lui
vainqueur au tour avec maxime abers sur
une semaine de troubles là bas il y a
des airs de telenovela rallye m'a le
scrutin présidentiel s'est clôturée le 6
juin dernier
mais les 33 millions de péruviens ne
connaissent toujours pas l'identité de
leur nouveau président dimanche dernier
le candidat de la gauche radicale pedro
castillo distançait sa rivale keiko
fujimori de quelques soixante mille
voire dès le lendemain du scrutin la
candidate de la droite populiste
dénonçaient des fraudes
accusations réitérées ce samedi à des
journalistes étrangers
il y à des fraudes dans le décompte des
bulletins et des faits graves dans cette
étape ultime
on paie très dans les affaires fugee
maury n'en est pas à sa première
tentative en 2016 déjà la fille de
l'ancien président alberto fujimori
avait traîné des pieds pour reconnaître
sa défaite face à pedro pablo cousine
ski cette fois elle dénonce les
ingérences de la gauche international du
côté des observateurs nationaux et
internationaux aucune irrégularité
malgré l'examen de dizaines de milliers
de bulletins dont toutes les réunions
l'organisation des états américains a
exprimé qu'elle a observée en processus
électoral positifs dont lequel des
améliorations substantielles ont été
enregistrés entre le 1er et le 2nd tour
de même la mission n'a pas détecté
d'irrégularités graves
de son côté pedro castillo félicité par
les présidents des pays voisins assurent
vouloir respecter le choix de ses
concitoyens
[Musique]
j'exprime ma gratitude aux hommes et aux
femmes de ce pays qui se sont levés ici
et à l'étranger et aux frères en dehors
du pays qui se sont mobilisés pour
défendre la démocratie
[Musique]
notre gouvernement sera respectueux de
la démocratie de la constitution
actuelle nous serons respectueux et nous
créerons un gouvernement avec une
stabilité financière et économique
[Applaudissements]
aucun des deux candidats n'a été déclaré
officiellement vainqueur alors que la
population péruvienne semble déchiré
depuis une semaine
partisans des deux candidats manifestent
dans plusieurs endroits de lima la
capitale
[Musique]
c'est une marche de protestation contre
la fraude communiste
nous voulons un pérou libre une
démocratie libre et nous allons rester
ici jusqu'à ce que les résultats
définitifs soient donnés ici ce que nous
faisons c'est protesté protester contre
ce que fait l'office national des
processus électoraux qui jouent un rôle
très sombre dans notre pays
ici nous entoure pour attaquer ceux qui
sont venus manifester ce n'est pas
correct
pedro castillo a déjà gagné au dernier
décompte vendredi castillo était en tête
avec 52,10 7% des voix mais toujours
aucune décision officielle alors que
s'ouvre une bataille judiciaire
l'examen de centaines de milliers de
bulletins contesté qui pourrait
repousser d'encore quelques semaines la
publication des résultats
enlisé dans une crise politique sans fin
les péruviens attente de connaître leur
cinquième président en trois ans
[Musique]
en israël le parlement vote en ce moment
pour valider le nouveau gouvernement
formé par guérir la petite au bénéfice
d'une coalition anti netanyahu outre se
débarrasser de l'actuel premier ministre
son objectif également représenter
l'ensemble des israéliens à lutter
contre le programme nucléaire iranien
hier soir des opposants à benyamin
nétanyahou se sont réunis devant sa
résidence pas pour demander sa démission
de cette fois mais pour célébrer leur
potentiel victoire écoutez les nous ne
pensons pas que nous avons la victoire
en poche
nous devons voir demain ce qu'il se
passera mais nous pouvons avoir un
espoir celui que demain nous aurons en
israël différents ou du moins nous
aurons une chance d'avoir un israël plus
brillants et meilleur les manifestations
sont la cause principale de
l'effondrement du gouvernement
netanyahou et demain nous aurons un
nouveau gouvernement
les chances sont de 99 % nous pouvons
certainement nous permettre de célébrer
ce moment
après avoir passé sept années de sang de
sueur de larmes à sortir dans la rue
sans savoir si cela changera quelque
chose à être frappés et arrêtés sans
raison tant de choses n'auraient pas dû
se passer mais ce sont pourtant produite
la nouvelle coalition hétéroclite sera
donc dirigé par nathalie bennett le chef
du parti de droite
yamina pendant deux premières années
ensuite ce sera au tour du centre et se
guérir la peep portraits des deux hommes
avec la machette
la coalition du changement est menée par
naftal bennett chef du parti
ultranationaliste
yamina l'homme d'affaires de 49 ans qui
a fait fortune dans la haute technologie
est entré sur le tard en politique c'est
en 2006 qu'il fait le morceau pour lui
les digues coude où il devient le bras
droit de benyamin nétanyahou
deux ans plus tard naftali bennet quitte
le parti pour diriger en temps le
conseil de yesha principale organisation
représentant les israéliens vivent dans
les colonies de cisjordanie des
implantations devenu le fonds de
commerce politique du millionnaire même
s'il n'y vis pas fizi migrants américain
le nationaliste religieux né dans le
nord d'israël a occupé pas moins de cinq
portefeuilles ministériels depuis 2013
le dernier en date celui pour la défense
en 2001 après avoir été un partenaire
incontournable de benyamin nétanyahou
naftali bennet passe dans l'opposition
en mars 2020 suite aux élections
législatives un an plus tard nouveau
scrutin le quatrième en deux ans le
premier ministre sortant ne parvient pas
à former une coalition
le mandat revient alors aux centristes
yaïr lapid ancienne star de la tv
israélienne le chef du parti hier à ty
est connu pour ses positions laïque
l'homme de 57 ans né à tel-aviv se place
bien volontiers comme porte-parole des
israéliens séculier il se définit aussi
comme un défenseur de la classe moyenne
sur le sujet sensible du conflit
israélo-palestinien et bien pas de
discours bien tranche
meyer lapide se dit favorable à la
création d'un état palestinien tout en
se montrant ferme avec l'autorité
palestinienne
on le voit tout semble opposer lire la
pid et naftali bennett est pourtant une
coalition les unit désormais le
gouvernement du changement composé de
huit parties un attelage improbable
allant de la gauche à la droite radicale
et avec à son bord pour la première fois
depuis des décennies un mouvement arabe
un ralliement qui a un prix politique si
la coalition annoncé reçoit le vote de
la knesset
naftali bennett sera promu
23 avant de céder son fauteuil à lire la
piste pour les deux années suivantes
une alliance hétéroclite d'opposants
politiques avec pour seul dénominateur
commun chasser benyamin nétanyahou qui
occupent le pouvoir en israël depuis 12
ans un record pour le géopolitologue
gérard epiard fondateurs du web magazine
le monde décrypté chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen orient
cette coalition envoie un message fort à
la population écouter la partie le
moment où vous avez une union vous avez
un rassemblement vous avez des
différences et je pense que le grand
défi du monde politique israélien c'est
de faire de cette différence une force
car ce qui se trouve effectivement au
centre la problématique israélienne
maintenant c'est d'éviter des conflits
religieux intercommunautaires
donc là il ya un signal fort du monde
politique
dans cette vision unitaire de 10 en
quelque sorte eh bien vous voyez vous il
n'y a pas lieu de s'affronter
car politiquement nous sommes unis donc
nous avons un dispositif politique qu'il
n'est pas idéologique qui n'a pas de
vision politique forcément très clair
donc qui veut être pragmatique et la
proclamation officielle des résultats
des législatives algériennes
elle n'interviendra pas tout de suite en
revanche le taux de participation il est
connu c'est le plus faible depuis 20 ans
30 % et ce n'est pas une surprise
puisque le scrutin avait été boycotté
par les partisans du irak est la journée
de vote qui n'a pas connu de
d'incidents a été tout de même troublé
en kabylie on voit cela avec ben hassen
chébili des élections législatives
anticipées largement boudée par les
algériens
un taux de participation de 30,20 %
c'est loin de l'objectif du gouvernement
qui tablait sur une participation à au
moins 50%
à titre de comparaison il se situait aux
dernières législatives de 2010 est à 35
avec le 70 % c'est en kabylie au nord du
pays que la participation a été quasi
nul avec 0 79% à béjaïa et 0 62% à tizi
ouzou les deux grandes villes de cette
région selon des chiffres officiels
préliminaires dans cette région du nord
de l'algérie le scrutin d'hier a été
marquée par des protestations et des
saccages d'urnes selon la ligue
algérienne des droits de l'homme de
nombreux bureaux de vote ont dû fermer
leurs portes bien avant 20h 136 centres
de vote et 229 bureau exactement un
scrutin apportées par les pro
gouvernement est largement boudés par le
irak et une partie de l'opposition qui
dénonce une mascarade électorale et
réclame toujours un changement radical
du système de gouvernance 407 députés
issus de plus de 1500 listes pour cette
nouvelle composition de l'assemblée
populaire nationale
les résultats attendus normalement
aujourd'hui pourrait être finalement
annoncé demain par l'autorité nationale
et indépendante des élections le liban
au bord d'une catastrophe humanitaire
pénurie d'hydrocarbures de médicaments
ou de produits de première nécessité le
pays du cèdre qui pointe du doigt les
dirigeants et cette semaine emmanuel
macron a même brandi la menace d'une
mise sous tutelle internationale les
précisions c'est avec françois disque et
beach
la tension est palpable devant cette
station-service de beyrouth des heures
d'attentes pour n'obtenir qu'une faible
quantité d'essence
une quête sans fin les libanais sont à
bout la situation est vraiment très
difficile et j'attends ici depuis une
heure et demie peut-être qu'ils auront
encore de l'essence quand ce sera mon
tour peut-être pas la situation est
insupportable
3h j'attends ici depuis trois heures au
début de la file
il y a encore 20 à 25 voitures devant
nous vous la situation ne fera
qu'empirer pénurie de carburant mais
aussi de médicaments de couches ou de
lait pour bébé
incapable de satisfaire leurs clients
les pharmacies se sont mis en grève ce
vendredi pour deux jours que dois-je
faire à la maison quand mon fils a
besoin de lait ou de couches lui dire
que je n'ai pas d'argent pour te les
acheter et même si j'en avais les
pharmacies sont toutes fermées tout le
système de santé du pays est touché
certains hôpitaux au même prévenu qu'il
pourrait être obligée de suspendre les
dialyses rénales
dès la semaine prochaine
c'est très dangereux
nous recherchons des médicaments pour la
tension artérielle du potassium et du
phosphore ainsi que des injections à
donner aux patients sous dialyse
nous sommes à la recherche de ces
médicaments nous appelons un million de
pharmacie pour obtenir une ou deux
seringue à donner aux patients pour
qu'ils puissent vivre une situation
résultat d'un différend opposant les
importateurs d'équipements médicaux à la
banque du liban
cette dernière voyant ces réserves se
réduire
menace de ne plus subventionner ces
importations comme elle le fait depuis
le début de la crise une crise politico
économique inédite qui dure depuis
presque deux ans sans gouvernement
depuis dix mois
la banque mondiale a une nouvelle fois
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
début juin affirmant que la crise
financière libanaise est l'une des pires
dans le monde depuis 1850 et c'est la
fin ce journal merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on va se retrouver en direct à
dans 30 minutes racheter avec mon sur rt
france
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier